andrew is with us in North Carolina hi
Andrew
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show hey Dave
hey you doing better than I deserve
what's up
well first really quick thank you so
much you've been such an inspiration to
my wife and I in terms of getting on the
same page our marriage with our finances
cool um and then a quick question I
think this for context we're on baby set
two but we purchased a modular cabin
from a company in Tennessee to be like
an in-law suite to help with childcare
and fortunate we don't have any debt for
that but we got a notice that that
company is filing for bankruptcy just
over a week ago and so I know nothing
about like you know their assets or
anything like that so I guess the
question would be you know that we're
trying to be get all intents about baby
set - should we try to hire a lawyer to
look into their assets and see if
there's anything to recoup on this or
how much money did you give them up
front for the cabin it was well it was a
$50,000 you know check to start the
cabin while you're in the well they're
exactly I mean is wasn't it there's
nothing a decision that we should have
made but it's a decision that has been
made and there's family reasons for it
we read you know boundaries that you
recommended we're really working on that
now but um needless to say the situation
we're in okay do you over the $50,000 to
someone we do not but you repaid you
prepaid for the cabin to be
pre-engineered designed and delivered to
you correct
in advance for a hundred percent of it
no no no that was that was the payment
and we worked we went to the site for
this place everywhere no I'm not asking
and I'm asking what the terms are so you
put a $50,000 ordeal that's how large
100 where you gonna let the other 500
we had the other 50 in cash again this
was a this was an in laws like sell the
home that had money and the point was
that to give them a new home okay now
the cabin company is supposed to deliver
you the package and you all build it or
they're supposed to build it on your
site to build it we prepare the ground
they deliver the cabin but obviously we
got notice of bankruptcy so I would
assume well here no I don't think that's
okay I don't I don't think they filed
chapter 7 I think they filed chapter 11
which means they're operating the
business now you are a creditor of that
business they do owe you a cabin or
$50,000 one of the two right but my
guess is they're intending to deliver
the cabin still okay they probably
didn't bankrupt on their customers they
probably bankrupt it on their vendor not
responding to emails or phone calls
anymore so hope might be they did close
I don't I don't know I know the company
I heard they found I know the company
and I heard they filed bankruptcy but I
didn't know it was that they closed
completely I thought it was a chapter 11
if it's a chapter 11 really three or
four weeks ago have you got have you got
the bankruptcy notice I can probably
pull it up in there okay if it's a
chapter 11 you've got a shot chapter 11
is a reorganization where they don't pay
some of their creditors and they
continue to operate if it's a chapter 7
you lost 50,000 bucks you know you're
not gonna get anything there's nothing
you gotta build on it and there's not
anything you you and you know you're not
going to get your money if they went so
far down that they're closing up they're
not going to send you the logs and your
money's been gone a while and you can't
get blood out of a rock and you don't
have any preference over any of the
other creditors if there is any money
after they liquidate all the assets of
the company they will distribute it to
the creditors and you will be on the
list you could follow a noted yeah
you'll get a you'll get an opportunity
to file anybody for that I you could you
can but I won't spend a lot of money on
it because you're probably going to get
a sub I am or my better hope for this
disaster is that that it's a chapter 11
and they're continuing to operate and
they've just shed themselves of some of
their other debt but they're going to
continue to try to keep the thing open
and the only chance they've got to doing
that of course is to continuing to make
cabins and delivering them right right
yeah that's okay what did you don't have
it on me what did you you know so this
is your your mother-in-law how this deal
happen a situation where we had a an
in-law that we've been caring for you
know and uh just for boundaries and you
know we were in a situation where we
wanted to have them close and not in our
physical house and so that's our that's
what helped us decide to make this this
is it okay
I'm looking online and I think it is I'm
trying to do it while I'm talking to you
and it's kind of weird on while I'm on
the radio but I think it's a chapter 11
and so I think you got a shot I may be
wrong but I cuz I'm just I'm just
glancing through this chapter 7 and
chapter 7 is what we all think of when
we think of bankruptcy that's the atomic
bomb and any of the IDA thing is
shutting down they're going to sell off
any equipment or assets that they have
and they're going to pay out to anybody
that is owed money including you but
that means that there's not much there
for them to do that with and most
chapter sevens the creditors don't get
any money or you may get five grand or
something on your 50 grand okay because
they don't have any money that's why
they closed down right right and there's
and and they're not required to do
anything else that's the point of a
chapter
wipes a slight slate clean a chapter 11
is a reorganization bankruptcy for
businesses or large personal situations
and that is they submit a plan to the
court to pay some of their creditors in
different classes and they continue to
operate I'll give you an example many
years ago
Kmart filed chapter 11 bankruptcy before
it finally did go broke two decades
later when it filed chapter 11
bankruptcy what they did was they had a
bunch of empty Kmart stores they were
still having to pay rent on that their
plan was they cut those off and kept the
and didn't have to pay anything their
plan was don't pay those landlords
anything and that way we become healthy
enough to keep the current stores open
and running and keep those jobs in place
the judge approved that plan so those
landlords all got their properties back
where these came empty Kmart buildings
on them but got no money the and then
Kmart kept operating and so if you had
money in laya if you had something in
layaway at Kmart as a customer you could
have gone in and got your layaway you
didn't get screwed right but a chap if
they'd file chapter 7 then everything
sold off and what little money is there
is used to pay towards creditors in
order of preference there's a preference
order on creditors in bankruptcy so
that's what you're facing and I wouldn't
spend a lot of money chasing money I
mean I'd spend five hundred bucks to
file the paperwork in case I'm in line
as a creditor and you should get a
notice of creditors and that kind of
thing if it's a chapter 7 but that's the
but if it's a chapter 11 I think you'll
probably get your house I'm sure you're
gonna want it I'm sure you should have
done it I know you should've done it but
I don't think you'll probably get it
sorry you're going through this though